So, uh my name is Chess. I have a PhD in
computational neuroscience. That's just
so you know I'm legitimate. Um and uh
and I also represent a company called
Co-node. I am the CEO and Johanna is our
VP of growth. Um please uh challenge her
with all the most technical questions. I
think she will do actually quite well.
Um I've been shocked at how much you uh
have been able to understand in such a
short period of time.
Um it's uh I on the other hand I'm going
to make things I'm going to make a mess
of things. Well, so let's get started
with that.
Here's our agenda.
Uh the problem, why hasn't GenAI
revolutionized business yet? I mean,
maybe none of us think that's a problem
cuz we're all here cuz we know it's
happening. But um but maybe it hasn't
happened as much as any as we expected
in the last 2 years of the LLM wave. Um
the solution of course of course is
going to be to ground GenAI in graphs.
Uh we're going to show some quick
examples of text retrieval which we have
all been seeing throughout this
conference and I think many of us
experiment with but it's just worth
seeing again. And how we can do some
kind of
broad-scale text retrieval uh that's
more about drawing conclusions from the
graph instead of just finding uh
things that you're looking for. Um and
then how we might solve what we think is
the hard part which is building the
graphs. Um
a little note on agentic AI cuz you have
to. Uh and then a couple examples and
then well, in conclusion. All right, so
the motivator for this talk I think is
where is my starship computer? So, I'm
going to ask for hands again. Who
thought
after the first time you experimented
with ChatGPT or Perplexity or any of the
the big popular LLMs,
who thought that it was going to be just
a matter of time,
maybe months, before you'd be able to
walk into your office and ask a natural
language question of the wall and then
have it come back like the Star Trek
Starship computer with the answer.
I was worried about it. I mean, I was I
was hoping we'd be part of this anyway.
Okay, nobody thought that. Okay, you
guys are way sophisticated.
So, I think a lot of people do think
that though. Perhaps perhaps more
business audience than this. They think
that they're that Starship computer's
going to happen. And I think we kind of
know it's it's going to take something
else for it to happen.
Not just answer questions, but show you
stuff that you didn't expect like
there's a Klingon warship approaching,
right? You don't query that. You but you
need it to tell you.
Um
So, I think a lot of I'm going to all
just skip past this. We know GenAI
hallucinates. This is a classic example.
At this point GPT-4 doesn't have this
problem anymore. It doesn't think people
cross the English Channel on foot. But,
if you really asked it, it would also
not tell you the times when people might
have walked through the channel. So, it
it still doesn't have an internal model
that a human could do. Um
Uh for this reason Goldman Sachs thinks
a lot of, you know, companies have
already wasted a trillion dollar in
CapEx on on GenAI. Maybe.
Maybe.
Um but we I think we a lot of people in
this audience already believe I'm
speaking preaching to the choir that
having some knowledge base in the
background to ground
the GenAI is a good solution. And in
fact, it is a perfectly good solution in
this particular case if we make a simple
graph that's got all of the world
records in it. It can answer this
perfectly perfectly accurately.
Um so
knowledge graphs are potentially great
background data source. Now, I've just
mentioned one particularly popular
project here, but there are many.
There's a lot of evidence that graph rag
that is to say retrieval through graphs.
I know most people here know what that
means. But, retrieval augmentation
generation or I'll just say retrieval
via graphs leads to a substantial
improvements over naive rag, perhaps
just simple vector rag. Um, and I would
also just highlight that the graphs that
you use for these may be architected in
a different way than graphs that we use
for social networks.
So, just
talking about retrieval, here are some
simple examples like trivial dashboards
that I built on top of a graph back end
that our company happens to produce.
And what you're seeing is that I'm
asking for different kinds of queries
that have very different qualities.
Sometimes, you know, like an individual
paper from a conference, sometimes a
summary of everything that was in the
conference. This is the back end. It's
got all the data in it in a graph that
you can look at and see. We might al-
also want to ask quantitative questions
that have to do with things that could
be derived from the graph but aren't
sitting in the graph. And so, if you
wanted to say calculate percent change
of two securities against each other,
which isn't something you can do on
Yahoo Finance easily, um, you could
still have a graph back end that
provided that kind of quantitative
answer even if it didn't represent a
fact that was sitting in a node in the
graph. And again, we happen to use this
sort of flexible knowledge graph in the
background that supports all of that.
So, I would say these are two examples
of the kinds of things, ways in which we
expect business users to be able to use
rag and a graph in the background is a
good way to do it.
Um,
not just us, I lots of people know this
already, but graphs and AI together are
getting really, really popular.
Uh, here's my
conceptualization of why it's better.
And again, I think this is a really
sophisticated audience, so I'd be
interested in what y'all think. But, I
would say that
the one of the ways in which it's just
clearly better than a non-graph solution
is because
you have a single source of truth inside
of graphs. And so, I find that that, um,
makes it in if I compare it to certainly
searching through any native database,
um,
it's much easier for the AI to sort of
construct the queries, if you will, or
match up with an embedding of the right
sub graph. I think others might have
different views on what graphs are
better, but that's my simplification of
it. Happy to entertain demurrals later
on.
So, um
So, why haven't they taken over yet?
Well,
I would Neo4j has made this quote, which
I've shown twice in this. This is the
harder part of graph rag is building the
knowledge graph. So, what's the what
what are the problems? Well, first of
all, constructing them is laborious,
especially if you decide on the ontology
beforehand, and if you've got to go
write notebooks in order to make a graph
that you can't see. Like, if you're
trying to make a graph that's got, you
know, that that references terabytes of
data and is maybe, you know, tens of
gigabytes, and you can't actually look
at it, then
you have to constantly guess what's in
it. It's like the worst of trying to
build databases in my experience. So,
you So, at at a very minimum for us,
having a lot of observability is an
important part.
And it gets for that same reason it gets
messy really fast. Um and sort of
violates your expectations in ways that
you don't expect if you can't see it. Um
I would also say that databases are so
themselves, traditional graph databases
are built to expect homogeneous data
types. So, they're made to like
think about individual people in a
social network that all have like a
finite number of properties and are
connected to other people. What they're
not meant to do is encode arbitrarily
levels arbitrarily the levels of
hierarchy inside of a
direct acyclic graph where you can have
concepts pointed to concepts pointed to
concepts, or even data that might
represent a concept depending on an
interpretation.
That's the kind of thing that I would
say you need a different differently
architected graph database for.
And then, I would also say that, yeah,
human assumptions inserted during
construction can make graphs inflexible.
So, I think these are the reasons why
it's going to be slow to construct a
knowledge graph. For what it's worth,
we've tried to solve some of that in our
company. You can read about this in
publications, or in this case in a in a
particular patent that happens to have
been granted. Um, we think that it's
quite useful to convert uh
all of the data into a graph
automatically,
um
look at all of it, and then uh start to
reduce it or start to collapse nodes in
order to come up with the best or most
economical subgraph that represents
everything that you might want to query
in your rag system.
So, I would be very pleased to go into
all this in detail, but short version is
you want to do as much automatic fusion
as possible.
You want to use uh lots of agents,
obviously, for structuring unstructured
text, but you want to have that process
be observable. Um and then you want to
be able to explore high-dimensional
distributions. So, look at lots of
embeddings of lots of different possible
clusters of data or subgraphs.
Um and then uh look at uh uh uh
co-distributions or look at two
distributions at the same time with two
things that might represent the same
thing, but you're not sure while you're
going through the sort of humanated
process of deciding, you know, what your
what your final graph is going to be.
Um I I should just also note like we're
all talking about agentic AI. AI agents
are going to be part of this.
The I don't think agentic AI means one
thing right now. Uh the video here is
happens to be sitting inside of our
graph, but is and anybody here can
access this is an overview of all the
agents or at least 400 of the agents
that are really, really powerful uh
popular right now. So, you can go and
navigate them in the space of agent
features if you like. Um you know, our
view of this was going to be graphs
themselves were going to act as the
medium for agents to interact. I'd be
very curious on everybody's views on
that anyway. But, short version is
you're going to need some set of agents
to help you construct your graph as it
gets complicated. So, bringing it all
together, I would say we need a fast uh
underlying graph database, uh ability to
calculate embedding embeddings fast,
that the deep connections inside of the
graph, and then its single source of
truthness provide an advantage for
getting deep, you know, transient but
true grounded insights
and that you need collaboration among
agents. So, again, we have a particular
solution. It's called Kônode. These are
actual screenshots from it. It
automatically fuses data in the way I've
said. It does no code and total
observability
in the sense that you can look at a lot
more of the data and connections than
you could with a normal framework.
You know, it's like you look at like
three or four times
three or four orders of magnitude more
than like Neo4j Bloom, for example.
It's fast
and it's got a lot of AI agents in it.
I've said some of this already, but
again, whether you're using our tool or
not, we think it's valuable to do fast
knowledge graph creation, fast data
fusion and prep, automatic ontology
design in the sense that you want the
ontology to be emergent. You don't want
to have to guess it ahead of time, but
if you have one, you want to insert it
as data and then you want to combine it
with the existing data inside the graph
instead of making it into like a
human-driven ontology design process. In
our case, we got really fast exploratory
data analysis which is part of the graph
creation process, very fast predictive
modeling.
You can do things like failure mode
detection for autonomous vehicles. We
have a lot of autonomous vehicle
developers, cut down on development
cycles and and it's really fun that it's
no code. Okay. I showed a little bit of
this before, but one use case is, you
know, transcontinental airline dumping
all their data automatically into a
knowledge graph and finding like a 10 to
30 million dollar savings opportunity in
like four hours. That was cool.
And I showed this video beforehand. This
is supposed to be a blitz talk, so I'm
not going to show it again until I
unless I get questions afterwards.
Another example is structuring clinical
text. You can have the graph sitting as
an ontology in the background. Once
you've gotten all the data in, it can
serve as an ontology in the background
for dynamic message translation. So, in
this case this is a This is a pilot we
did
with a
healthcare data provider in which the
graph that you're seeing on the left
there represented all the ideas that we
were pretty sure we were looking for in
the messages and dramatically by having
that ontology in the background of the
LLM-based message translation
dramatically improve the accuracy.
Um
and then continuous AI improvement. This
is something just kind of fun. I can
show a video of this. Um so, in this
case this is an autonomous vehicle
developer. And this is I think again,
this is going to look like a data
science example, but I think what it's
really showing is the power of getting
deep insights inside of a graph. So, um
what you see here is a graph in which a
bunch of behaviors from autonomous
vehicles are encoded. And so, you've got
a lot of
dimensions or observers on the left-hand
side. A graph that represents a lot of
features. Uh on the bottom right you
have a single risk measure which happens
to have been calculated from those
features. On the top right you have a a
map which is also encoded in the graph.
And you can see that the high-risk ones
have been um highlighted as as as large
and red. And you can't see anyone
particular pattern here, but because
we're using a graph, we can find the
pattern if it's buried in the graph
through one or potentially multiple
layers going backwards inside of the
feature space encoded in the graph.
So, in this case we're using what we
call one of our agents. Although, I will
be honest with you guys this one is the
least AI of all the agents because it's
running a Kolmogorov-Smirnov test in the
background. There, I gave it away. Um
and uh but what it's doing is it's
running that test hunting back through
the graph which is kind of the cool
part. And it's already showing us what
the pattern is, but if you want to see
it in a way that's a little bit easier
to visualize,
uh you can take with our little agent
drawer on the right-hand side you can
take the output of the agent and make it
into more graph. So, that's what we're
doing here. You can see that it's
identified that what's common among all
of those is that it's an optic obstacle
hazard and not all of the other
features.
And then
uh and then lo and behold, you can
just that's a that's a reminder that
everything's just connected inside this
graph. And then uh you get to look at
some fun
3D ray traced. Yeah, I said that really
is a failure mode. So, um and you'd be
surprised how often autonomous vehicle
developers have trouble finding those
failure modes in this very high
dimensional space. And I think that's a
real benefit of having a graph.
All right. This is meant to be a blitz
talk, so I'm going to end with the thing
I'm most proud of. We have a really
really fantastic team. I've introduced
Johanna already, but um there's a lot
more where that came from. Most of us
are here in London.
Uh uh although we have a little bit of a
pied-à-terre in Southern California as
well.
All right. So, in conclusion, problem,
GenAI hasn't revolutionized business
yet. Solution, grounding GenAI great
GenAI with graphs.
Um we showed a couple examples of how
that could work. Um and uh how we can
capitalize on it. And so, I would say in
conclusion, if you hadn't thought of it
already, please consider using graphs
for your ongoing AI efforts.
Basta.
>> [applause]
>> Any questions? Thank you for joining.
Any questions, please.
>> Yeah, um if you don't have any knowledge
of your domain and you just have a bunch
of data
and you just throw it in the graph,
how can you
create the right
nodes? Yeah, let's just call them the
right things. I mean, I'm let's just say
I've got
lots of source of data. I've got client
data, customer information, counterparty
information,
you know, one could argue they're all
the same. And then how do you then
disambiguate and then actually say, you
know, these are all the same thing?
>> Right. [snorts]
>> Entity resolution, I guess as well, but
semantic resolution as well as entity
resolution.
>> I think that we can all agree that the
that the idea of the statement graph
cannot be the solution to that entire
problem, right? Cuz if it could be, you
do it all automatically and then the
graph would be incidental, right?
So, there has to be something where the
graph is under human control, right? And
if you don't have any idea what's in
there, you either have to develop an
idea or somebody else with the access to
your graph has to know it or something
like that.
So, um or maybe there's an agent that
somebody else had trained, you know,
that they can help. So, maybe there's a
nice intermediate stage there someplace.
I'm going to tell you how we do it right
now because I I think that's most
interesting to everybody in here.
Again, I'm going to talk about our
product, but I think it's also sort of
telling of what, you know,
I'm not the smartest person on this team
and other people on the team do the same
thing.
So,
we toss all the data in our graph and
then usually
usually for us there's a customer. And
so we ask them what's important to them
and then we have a a family of ways of
finding of creating that it's like some
predictive feature, we just store it
inside the graph. Now, if it's already
in one of the fields in one of their
structured databases, it's easy.
But if it isn't, we now have this like
little family of agents that help with
this. So, we have this little panel on
our tool on the right-hand side
and we have these agents. One of them is
called the featurizer and one of them is
called the retrieval agent. And they all
operate on the graph in different ways.
And for the most part, they're
translating it into some LLM
understandable thing and sometimes doing
graph rag on their own. And they help us
you can say, "Okay, I've got 100
different fields in here. I've no idea
what they mean, but just find me all the
ones and rank how likely they are to
represent something that has to do with
monetary value." And it does an
excellent job at that. And then you get
like one of those ranking plots. I
showed one of those before. This is how
likely that the gen AI thinks that this,
you know, these acronyms have to do
with, you know, or another use case
which we're we're doing in in a pilot
right now with I can't say who but a big
four accounting firm is is
is uh
forensic accountant.
And if you don't know the entities
you're looking for and you don't even
know whether there are any entities, you
can ask the agents to just pull out
ideas from the text that wouldn't
normally be there.
And then the agents do that and then you
can in the graph start seeing how
frequently they're mentioned, start
seeing how unusual they are in English
language. And that's a way of starting
to start derive information. And then
when you've done that it becomes more
graph that then becomes queryable for
downstream processes.
Was that a decent answer to long-winded
not I not I hope.
All right. So that's how we do it right
now. I think it's I think all that's
going to get
more and more automated in ways that we
can all imagine is really interesting,
you know, like in my conception, we all
just sit on one massive graph and we're
in charge of a bunch of AI agents that
are constantly extracting value out of
the the bit of the domain that we are
responsible for and have control over.
Uh but we can always see what they're
doing and see whether it makes sense. I
hope it gets that gets that way.
Yeah, go ahead.
>> Just for the recording.
Yeah, I mean I have lot lots of
questions some of which we can sort of
like talk about later. I I guess my main
question is around this automated
ontology inference.
>> Yeah.
>> So I'll give you an example. So we've
been working on this for about a year.
Let tree as in like we're a huge
customer of theirs.
>> Great.
>> And if you automate your ontology or
even your graph structure,
the deduplication process becomes really
tricky sometimes and you get over
representation especially in big graphs
which then come out when you then say
build a conversational agent interface
on top of it or even if you do something
like structural analysis. So
>> Absolutely.
>> Let me give you an example. Let's say
um,
we're working with a fund. They want to
use graphs to kind of like get the data
room,
graphify it, and then
basically shortcut on due diligence. I
think it's a horrible idea, but
regardless, that's what they're trying
to do. And then when they start doing a
sort of structural analysis, they're
like, "How many of the nodes that have
been derived in this graph represent,
say, information about customers?" And
if you don't deduplicate that properly,
and and or you don't know the
domain-specific terminologies that these
people use, you get these
over-representations.
And so it kind of throws the whole thing
off. And so it feels like there's a
solution out there, but I'm I'm like I'm
still uncomfortable with automated
ontologies for this reason. So I just
wanted to know what you thought about
that.
>> But but but maybe you would allow that
that if you've got a system that tries
to automate it and has even a little bit
of uncertainty and then flags that the
the things it doesn't want to automate
for you for you,
that that there might be like some
savings there in terms of time, right?
So like this happens this I'm playing
this little video this tiny video, but
this happens to be an example in which
we had healthcare data in which somebody
had inserted another field that they
needed to use for a a different app that
had almost complete duplication, but not
total duplication with another field and
I put an underscore in front of it. And
you if you can flag those things when
they're in there, then you don't you
don't treat it like it's a whole, you
know, set of people with completely
independent names, you fuse the ones
that are that that are in common, and
then you just take the the little ones
that are on the side and add another
node and know to treat them differently,
you know, in all your processes. So
it
I maintain that it's possible to
flag
problems with duplication, problems
with, you know, anomalies inside of just
large data distributions
and rank them in the process of
constructing the graph as opposed to
going through every field one by one.
That's I mean that right that is I I'm
that's not Yeah, all right. And so I
you know, for what it's worth, if you
want to try it with this particular
tool, you might find that there's some
savings in that process. Very, very
pleased to you know
riff for an hour on some actual data.
Any other questions?
It was a good last question, actually.
>> [laughter]
>> All right. Well, thanks all. That was
very enjoyable.
>> [applause]